[Music]
do
[Music]
for me in the wildlife with the animals
that you're going to encounter so that
you know what the behaviors are learning
how an animal behaves
where it's likely to be found or how to
find them is half the half of what you
need to do
the other thing is i feel very fortunate
that i
collaborate with usually world experts
who have in an area of either local
knowledge or knowledge about something
specific and can give even more in-depth
understanding into the animal behavior
the location the currents or what that
i'm going to anticipate so that i can uh
put myself in the right places but i
think one of the things that i
i look back on my early life i think it
was diving and taking pictures because i
loved it
and learning about the animals and their
behaviors allowed me to find the animals
first and you know not everything just
swims right in front of you and so
obvious like the little things can be
the most the most interesting but
learning to to find something subtle is
really wonderful and sometimes like if
you can just imagine walking down the
street you don't notice the way the
leaves blow the first time but if you
walk it over and over again all of a
sudden the scent of the road the way the
leaves move and those little rhythms
become much more interesting and so
having a little more familiarity lets
you get more comfortable to get those
more intimate moments that maybe only
you see or that a few other people who
experience it see and photograph our
periods uh
a photograph so i think that that's
to me what a lot of preparation allows
for
um all while having the understanding
that things happen like this and you
have to be ready to react and react in a
moment's notice especially when i'm
photographing other people
um
like in cuba i
i like to
talk to them a little bit before i make
photographs of them
mostly because i'm not i wasn't only
there to
just to photograph but i also wanted to
learn from their stories and learn their
experiences
and from that
it helped inform
how i wanted to take the image
where i would want to take the image if
we wanted to include some like artifacts
of theirs and such like that and a lot
of the times it was also like a
collaboration with them
of how they wanted to photograph like be
presented in the photograph
like that one of the photographs the
older couple on the steps um that's
haavo and and ld when i was
photographing them he's like i wanna you
to snap the picture when when i'm like
bringing the like the bottle up to my
lips so he's like i want you to show me
like drinking this and so a lot of times
it's this
it's a collaboration with the people of
um
kind of in their own personalities and
experiences within the image rather than
either projecting my
view or my
ideology i guess on them um
and having a little bit more of their
voice within the image
well i'm trying to document a lot of
natural behavior so i would like to have
as little
uh direct impact
on the animals in the underwater world
what's really amazing
is they have to want to come close i
mean it's a big ocean out there and they
can swim away quite easily
so in order to do this there has to be
some sort of
little momentary connection between the
animal and myself
to be able to get to a range where i can
actually make a picture that's that's uh
reasonable
and so it's a wonderful sort of feeling
to learn how to move your body to
interact in a place to be a silent
observer but also to be uh someone that
that can be in a position to actually
capture uh something that's that's
occurring a feeding behavior a mating
kind of thing a
curious
whale that wants to swim up to you that
that is interested in something
uh shark that that is is interested in
in sort of moving around you and so
those
moments uh you know are natural and
happen
uh on their own way but uh getting in
the right place or positioning oneself
for those to happen is really an art
form in and of itself and something i
also spend a fair amount of time
working on is how to be in the right
place at the right time and you always
want to be in two places and you're
never in the right place and nor do i
ever have the right lens and all that
kind of stuff and so they're all a
million reasons why things don't work
out um but every now and then you have
success and it feels really wonderful
i'm definitely trying to engage in the
environments that i'm photographing
mostly because i want to create those
relationships but also like having the
camera that i have walking around a lot
of these like small towns
um in cuba a lot of times
we would hear like chatter of like
people like like i would be known
in that little town of like that'd be
like this
person walking around with this
big contraption thing
yeah when i when i want to photograph um
i definitely want to
connect as much as i can with the people
and
create a relationship
it's really the power of observation for
me that is is what's so interesting and
i really enjoy that moment and i enjoy
it not just with the camera to take the
picture but i enjoy the power of
actually learning to look um and
watching something for a while and i
find that to be one of the most
enjoyable experiences to just sort of
sit and look
even when i'm not photographing i want i
keep on observing trying to find like
the little details that like really make
a scene
um and make like almost mental images in
my mind of like
[Music]
inspiration of like possibly making that
image later
[Music]
in terms of tips for for people i think
one thing is to
pick something that is easily accessible
so in my case um
you know i like wildlife but so if we
were thinking of animals you know i
might pick animals that are local if
it's a robin that has a nest right in
your yard a squirrel cat or something
that you're comfortable with and think
of what what do you want to say about
that animal or that plant or what would
you like it to look like and what time
of day are you photographing this
instead of having things be arbitrary
pause for a moment and think what do you
want the image to say what would you
like to tell someone about that plant
why do you like that flower that stopped
and took that picture
and then begin to think about what are
the shape the form the color the time
and what is it that you really like
about it that caused you to pause in
that way and i think as you begin to
question yourself of what you want to
say about it the images
i would encourage you to then take a few
other images and say well how can i
enhance what it is i would like to
convey about it do i want to be close to
somebody do i want to be far from it do
i want to be looking down do i want to
be looking up
and you know i think those are the
elements
that you begin to have and so instead of
it just oh i snapped this picture and i
really liked it to notice them and to
really begin to sort of ask yourself
what you want to say about it with
photography think about a topic or
an emotion or something that you're like
deeply involved with or passionate about
or
that you find yourself wanting to
express or talk about and then think of
the ways that
um
you can
showcase that within photography
and i would just end on one quick thing
golfing is easy bike riding is easy but
these people practice over and over
again and no one believes me but it's a
skill to do this stuff and you have to
practice this over and over again and i
love doing this photography and i'm sure
katarina does as well
um and so it's it's something you do
over and over again and so it's not just
that i walk up to something and i get
one time lucky on this although maybe
that does happen these are skills that
i'm working on constantly on getting
myself ready so the reflexes boom i'm
right here with the camera and i'm ready
for it boom my lights are right where i
want them you know i'm thinking i'm very
aware of those things and i think that
that practice is really critically
important in the art of photography and
storytelling at whatever subject you're
interested in photographing so my number
one tip is to find a subject that you
like photograph it
and think about what you want to say
about it
you